CHRISTOPHER BROADFOOT: Hello.
Welcome to this week's Google
Maps Developer Shortcuts.
I'm coming to you from the
Sydney studio, where we have
new couches and I have a little
more facial hair after
Google I/O. Speaking of I/O, if
you haven't already watched
my talk, I strongly
suggest you do.
It's called When Android Meets
Maps, and it gives you a run
down of the Google Maps Android
API and some of the
cool things you can
do with it.
So speaking of cool things, I
talked a little bit about this
utility library at I/O, and
today, I've extended it a
little bit more.
So it's called the
android-maps-utils library.
It has a poly util, a spherical
util, and as of
today, a Bubble Icon Factory.
So let's talk about poly
util just very quickly.
At the moment, it has
one function.
It's decode.
It will take an encoded
poly line or
polygon, which is a string.
You might get this from the
Google Directions API, and it
will give you back a list of
latitude and longitude points.
Spherical util is great if you
need to do things like compute
distances between points, areas,
headings between two
points, or simply interpolate.
Perhaps you want to
animate a marker
between Sydney and France.
You can cycle through that
third value to get a nice
smooth line between
Sydney and France.
There's many more functions.
These are just a
small sampling.
So let's talk about Bubble
Icon Factory.
Essentially, it just
lets you generate
marker images like this.
These sort of look like info
windows, but each marker is
always showing.
So this is great for showing
small snippets of information
such as house prices,
as you can see here.
It's really simple.
You just create a new Bubble
Icon Factory, and
you call Make Icon.
And you pass out a string, and
that string will be shown
within that marker icon.
You get back a Bitmap, which
you can pass through to the
Bitmap descriptor factory.
And you just add that
to your marker
through the icon option.
Of course, you can use setIcon
to change that marker later.
So you can change
the color it it.
Here you can see that
we've got white
markers and green markers.
So you can just call Set Style
on the factory and just say
that you want a green style.
You can change these styles at
any time, so you can, for
example, set a whole bunch of
styles on the factory or maybe
create separate factories
for two
different types of markers.
It's really up to you.
So the other neat thing
about this is that
you can rotate markers.
Here you can see that we've
got markers that
are pointing downwards.
So this is great for a small
snippet of information once
again, like house prices, where
you don't really want to
interfere with the
map too much.
So we've gone a little bit
crazy with colors here.
You might want to stick to one
or two different colors.
But the library ships with a lot
of different styles that
might suit your application.
It's just the orange, red,
purple, blue and green.
So as I said, you can set the
rotation of the marker.
You can rotate the marker
itself or just the
content within it.
So with these markers where
the text is just pointing
down, we just set the content
rotation to 90 degrees.
Now, you could have markers
that are sticking outwards
like a little tag as well.
That's all quite possible.
You can also change the content
view completely.
For instance, if you'd like to
display an image within that
little bubble, you
can do that too.
You just call Set
Content View.
Perhaps you want to pass an
image view down to that.
And instead of calling Make Icon
with a string, you just
call Make Icon, and you
get back that Bitmap.
So a little tip--
these can be run off the main
thread, off the UI thread, so
you could go and generate all of
these in parallel or in the
background, perhaps
in an async task.
And once it's generated back on
the UI thread, go on, put
that marker onto the map.
So go and check it out.
It's on github.com/googlemaps.
It's distributed as an Android
library project, much like
Action Bar Sherlock or
something like that.
You're probably familiar
with it.
Actually, in fact, you're
already familiar with it if
you're using the Maps API,
because the Google Play
services client is distributed
as a library project.
So just go ahead and drop that
into your project, and you can
start using this poly util,
spherical util, and the Bubble
Icon Factory.
Well, I hope that helps, and
I'll see you around next time.
Thank you.